right president biden and democrats have
a huge political problem on their hands
vice president kamal harris
the vp's poll numbers are dropping like
a rock and there is concern
harris could doom democrats in the
midterms maybe it's because of moments
like these
do you plans to visit the border
um not today
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe you're
going to have to
um xerox are
photocopy your id people live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max so jesse
republicans in california are really
excited because she's going to go out
and help gavin newsom with his recall
and they think it'll be really good for
them
well it might with gavin but anybody in
a real swing district they're not
sending her she's underwater in the real
clear politics average and that is hard
to do as a democrat
and i looked at the trend line and it
really started to dip once
joe put her why are you laughing you
know they rigged poles richard
she really started to plummet when biden
put her in charge of the border and she
flaked
now the democrats knew she wasn't that
politically talented remember when joe
tapped
her she didn't even get a bump and then
when she debated
pence he mopped the floor with her if it
wasn't for the fly on his head it would
have been
a perfect game and then you know the
rest is cackling and dodging and now
she's jealous
of jill because jill's getting good
press and her staff doesn't even like
her so
a vp is a huge asset especially in the
midterm
she's young she can travel her schedule
is more flexible
and you deploy her very strategically
you're not really going to be able to
deploy her where you want to deploy her
because it could backfire and that kind
of goes to joe
it tells you what who joe is as a
politician
to pick someone that bad as their number
two richard
i i i guess uh look here's the truth
when was the last time we did a segment
of like a whole segment about mike pence
or
he's not the vice president no but this
is my point or dick cheney they're not
the president don't try to change the
subject
um but my point here is i think the
reason why she's getting such a harsh
critic is because she's the first woman
to take
come on you're better than that on top
of it you're
better than that it's the facts that's
fake that's not the best
okay and the media was so nice to sarah
palin yeah so nice if you'll remember i
i will appear that the media wasn't nice
to sarah palin because she was also a
woman running for vice president
right i'm not gonna i'm not gonna mix
apples and oranges i'm gonna call it
spade to spaghetti
media is sexist against women no i'm
saying that they treated both sarah
palin
but they treated jill fine unfairly when
they're in when they're both when they
were candidates and when they're not now
that she's the vice president
i think also that it's very early in the
vice president's term and it's very very
in the president's term
we haven't she has been on the campaign
trail yet she hasn't started campaigning
what she has been doing is raising money
for the party she's doing that very
effectively so she's doing part of her
job effectively and i think we have to
wait to see
what happens here greg yeah you know um
uh i don't think joe picked her
that's the first part it was somebody
else picked her it was uh definitely uh
the
uh the deal that he had to make the dems
thought they
actually drafted a capable backup
quarterback in her but they got an
erratic
place kicker who whiffs almost all the
kicks and you got to be on i mean she is
just not
too i i'm defending her on this she's
not into it
she didn't like it i know i've been
there i would see it yeah
right now the anxiousness the nervous
laughter the
the exhaustion i remember i was a tech
writer briefly in silicon valley
freelancing it was so over my head i'd
show up and just nod and smile
and just talk in vagaries and
generalities exactly what she did
i thought that her her flaws could be
remedied her nervous giggle
her sense of exhaustion it always gave
the impression that she was a
lightweight
and that she's the wrong person for the
wrong job but it hasn't changed and what
made it worse is even the
the root cause term paper that they
assigned her oh yeah it felt like
it was an assignment that i did in grade
school on ulysses s
grant where i went home and rewrote the
encyclopedia britannica
everything that was in her thing could
have been cobbled together from
wikipedia she didn't have to actually go
there
nothing in that make work term paper
assigned to her
came across as anything you know
innovative or fresh it was just you know
kind of embarrassing so i think that
they they're gonna have to make a
decision soon
uh the up one upside to her is that
right now she's created a bar
so low that anytime she does something
halfway decent will be considered a
success in the media
all the they want to root for her there
is no dis that nobody's being sexist
towards her
they want her to uh succeed so she just
does something
something tiny that's right they'll be
all over her so shannon
if you look at the polling actually
women aren't so fond of
the vice president regardless of
political party yeah and
do you remember during uh the the
primaries and during the campaign we got
a memo that came out from a number of
large women's groups that said we're
watching you
and if you be any criticism of her we're
going to know that you're sexist you
guys remember that memo with several
pages large women just large women
large group oh oh lord women's groups
not large women large groups of women
representing women
but said you can't talk about her
because if you do it's going to be
sexist and it's going to be bad but i
don't know that
anybody should be surprised that she's
that the american people haven't warmed
to her she
dropped out of the primaries in single
digits she wasn't able to fundraise at
that point
so it wasn't like there was an
overwhelming thirst for her during the
primaries and
um she's gonna have to find a way to
connect but they're giving her some of
the toughest assignments
and there is grumbling around washington
among her staff and people who feel like
she's getting the crappy assignment she
gave she gave a single digit to her
staff
allegedly for 240 years we've had women
in this country for the first time we've
elected women to vice president i'm
proud to see kamala harris there and i
want to see her do the best job possible
because we should have a woman in the
oval office she's doing a very bad job
now so maybe she can improve
fan mail friday is up next hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else